with us now is the Florida Governor
Rhonda Santas who's kind enough to join
us on the phone governor thank you for
joining us what what about these ships
woody what are you gonna do yes I think
actually we're gonna have a solution you
know when this first came on our radar
you know I was told that these ships
were all foreign nationals and then they
had no connection to Florida so I was
just like why would you just bring them
to Florida it turns out there are
American citizens and we actually have
Floridians I think there's 30 or 40
Floridians and so the county is working
on a plan to be able to get the
Floridians back safely safely expatriate
their foreign nationals so that they're
not mixing with our community I've
offered National Guard's support to be
able to help in that effort there we
were concerned about a deluge into the
hospitals but I think it turns out that
there will probably be some who will
need to go but it's very very manageable
and the local hospital system thinks
that they can handle it so I actually
think that they're going to be able to
deal with this in a way that make sense
and obviously once we found out that
there were American citizens and
Floridians especially onboard you know
we wanted to find a way to make it work
there was though there is a concern of
course given that we have most of our
cases down in those two counties that if
you had folks infected and then they
were going to the airport or going to
different areas you know that could
potentially spread continue to help the
spread but I think that they have it
figured out so it'll all be done safely
and I'm hoping that they'll be able to
come to a resolution on that very soon
would they dock in Fort Lauderdale where
would they go yeah I think they would
but what would happen is they would you
know the Floridians obviously there's
some of the Floridians live right in
Broward and some of the other Floridians
you know would be taken to you know
where where they're where they're from
the foreigners they it I think there
would be flights arrangement they will
not go in the airport it'll be done to
where there's not going to be an
opportunity to spread coronavirus to the
people of Florida so I think it's a
thoughtful approach that they're working
on and hopefully the the cruise line
will you know be willing to agree to
some of the terms of County once but
look at the end of the day Neal I mean I
think that we've seen these
be big problems with this virus and I
know they're not sailing you know any
new ones but you know this is this is
going to continue to be a problem and so
we just want to make sure that people
are safe both on those ships but
particularly on shore in places like the
state of Florida governor today you also
issued a stay at home order many of your
critics and Democrats who wrote letter
to you to say that you shouldn't put
this off you've done that how will it
how will it work when does it take
effect well so just so your viewers know
you know southeast florida has 60% of
our cases we have done stay at home in
conjunction with the mayor of miami-dade
so they've been under restrictions for a
couple weeks now some counties some
night counties have half a million
people that have only a handful of cases
so we did have not done it statewide but
in our hot spot that had been done now
with the president doing the extra 30
days you know my view is is look the
countries hit the pause button we've hit
the pause button this is the number one
two three priority I know there was talk
about getting the economy back a little
sooner but I think that unless we just
deal with this and so I felt it made
sense to extend it statewide and
obviously we have a lot of parts of
Florida that haven't been hit as hard as
Miami or Broward but we want to keep it
that way and we don't want to see you
know more spread and in those areas if
it's how do you just southeast Florida
that's kind of our epicenter we've put a
lot of resources down there we don't
want there to be a massive surge
obviously but but we've got a lot of
resources staged there so so I think
it's the best policy for the state at
this time
how are you policing the beaches and
crowds going to the beaches I mean
hundreds thousands of miles of if you
think about it I'm just yeah we did we
have no crowds on any public space of
ten or more and so some places just
closed every public space because they
don't want to police it some people let
people go to a park whatever but what
happens is you know our whole state is a
coastline and so you can have a beach be
closed but guess what unless you're
policing it 24/7
people go out there so I was flying out
of Miami we're going up the coast you
know I see a slew of beaches that are
quote closed but I mean you do that
people go out there so this is kind of
like whack-a-mole people are going to do
different things but you know a lot of
the stuff in the media that was played
about like the spring break that was
before the CDC had changed their
guidance you know so they were saying a
thousand people groups were fine that
was like four days before the 15 days to
stop the spread so it escalated quickly
and then once that happened you know the
groups were banned all throughout the
state of Florida so we are seeing other
areas of the standing people do
congregate in private residences and
other things and we have 21 and a half
million people I mean it's it's it's
definitely definitely change most people
have been doing a great job and I want
to thank the people Florida for doing a
great job Thank You governor very very
much you know you're quite busy Roxanne
is the governor the beautiful state of
Florida right now we're a stay at home
order is now or will be I building
tomorrow night in effect